thanks so much everybody for coming uh
so
i'm pascaline from the square new york
office we opened the office like six
months ago um
and so i'm a new transplant to new york
uh which is it's been a lot of fun so
tonight what i'm going to focus on is
how to avoid outages
and really kind of the underlying theme
of what i'm going to present which are
kind of a survey of a bunch of insights
that we've learned you know at square
and in previous companies that that we
all came
uh from
is technology is great but what's even
better is to have a culture of safety
and actually have kind of a focus around
kind of this devops integration
and and how to make things
you know secure and safe you know from
the ground up so you think about square
we've grown from this really tiny little
company
four years ago to running you know more
than 20 billions of payments today
we have over a million over a million
merchants using us
uh you know every month
and whenever we have outages you know
there's real people who are hurt who are
unable to kind of sell their products
and so for us the focus on
on on safety and the focus on having our
system stable has been absolutely
constant
so i thought
i'd start with
someone who's kind of an inspiration for
me paul o'neill who's the ceo of a
former ceo of alcoa
who managed the company from 87
to 99 so over a 10-year
tenure
and over his tenure he was able to kind
of multiply the net profits from roughly
200 million which is not too bad to over
1.4 billion of net revenue so enormous
growth over
over his tenure and
on the first earnings call
after he was nominated
he kind of
freaked out everybody on the street so
he was on the call he said well you know
i'm going to focus on safety like i'm
not going to focus on
market share or
productivity or whatever i'm going to
focus on worker safety and that's going
to be my single focus
for the next few years and everybody
thought he was absolutely crazy
to to basically focus on you know the
employees and focus on
the the factories but what happened is
through many conversations
he was able to kind of change the tone
in the company one of the things he did
is he gave his personal phone number at
the time there wasn't a lot of cell
phones
his home phone number to every employee
in the company
and he said you know if there's any
issue related to safety call me
personally any time of the day and i'll
attend to it
and so one day you know someone in a
factory
in a remote part of the country
noticed something wrong with a conveyor
belt and you decide okay well you know
the ceo asked me to be proactive about
this i'll call him up at his house so he
calls up you know paul o'neil he's
probably about 10 layers away from the
co
you know this big massive company over
50 000 employees
and talks to him about you know the fact
that this conveyor belt is broken and so
yeah exactly focus on safety
and so
paul o'neill basically you know took the
call thanked the guy
called the general manager of that of
that plant and by the next morning the
conveyor belt was fixed and little by
little
through those practices not only was he
able to improve productivity for obvious
reasons you know when you have things
that work smoother you know you increase
productivity but he was also able to
kind of create a real conversation with
employees and basically change uh the
setting in the company and de-unionize
the company
and make it just more efficient all
throughout and that's one of the many
ways that he succeeded and i think it's
a nice kind of analogy in a world that's
maybe a little far from us you know
manufacturing uh to to kind of take into
uh something that is so kind of
ephemeral you know software
and you know very much like with great
describe now you always speak about code
something than profit
i'll actually say that you know there's
two part of our job we write code and
then we remove code and we're really
happy when we move when we remove code
and then in between there's a bunch of
things that happen and so
we'll kind of go on a journey through
each step and look at you know different
techniques for each of them so once
we've written code we're actually going
to bless that code you know some people
call that quality assurance testing you
name it but the whole concept is you've
got code and you need to basically make
a determination on whether that code is
good or bad
then you take that and you ship it to
your customers in order to get value
and to basically deliver value to those
customers
hopefully the code is going to live and
so you have to maintain it and make sure
that continues to behave as expected
and then you know at some point you hope
to profit from that code in whatever way
and finally you remove it you know
and so
the the first thing that we're going to
start by is the actual coding part
i could probably do
you know full talk just on coding or
many many talks people spend their whole
life on how to code effectively there
are two things which which i wanted to
mention as you know little snippets of
you know thing to think about you know
and kind of take a step back about how
to write code so one of the issues i've
noticed often is when you're writing
front-end systems
uh things which basically access a bunch
of backends
i've noticed developers mixing id so you
have a customer id you have a user id
you have a basket id and then
you know you're not careful
code gets complicated you try to batch a
request and then you're going to use
one kind of id for another kind of id
and so that leads to you know obvious
bugs data leaks you name it so two
techniques that um
that i've seen used in practice you know
the first one actually comes from google
checkout back in 2006
is typed id so basically you know
leverage the type system uh to create
kind of this surrogate type uh and type
annotation type tokens
to be able to have the type system
basically tell you that you're mixing
things incorrectly the other one is
simply using textual ids
and randomizing those textual ids so
that they have a much lower probability
of colliding
one more trick is to actually add have a
type
identifier at the end of the id the
reason you would want to add it at the
end is to make sure that you can
continue to have high selectivity if you
ever write them in databases and do kind
of search on that
so that's kind of the first thing on
encoding the other is testable
configuration so one of the systems we
built at square is called trek on it's a
reverse proxy so think about you know
nginx or varnish
but the focus of that system was around
testable configuration
so one of the thing we noticed is as the
company grew people got scarier you know
it got scarier and scarier to actually
modify you know that top level
configuration that basically spreads the
traffic across all of our different
back-end system
and so we were kind of ranking our
brains about how to make it better
and so what we came up with is you know
we had like some rudimentary amount of
testing around nginx but we decided to
shift gears completely and instead build
a system where by design the
configuration of the system was very
very testable and so we basically ended
up with a reverse proxy that has a
configuration that is
very easy to read very stylistically
written
almost like a mini
domain specific language and then
with that comes a testing language where
you can express all your rules so if
you're on one team and you actually care
about five different kind of urls uh
moving into your system and being routed
to your system you can encode all those
invariants and then
know that
you know whatever other people are going
to change that configuration they won't
break your system and so that has really
kind of
catalyzed our ability to kind of behave
uh as a group and all kind of contribute
to that
so then you know once you're kind of
done with coding
you have to basically test things or
bless code
test driven development today is not
controversial uh it's basically the run
of the mill thing that everybody does
a decade ago it wasn't the case like
there's many systems on which i worked
even in financial industry
doing routing orders in major banks
you know wires
checks and basically processing for
those kind of entities that had
literally absolutely no tests you know
three millions out of three million
lines of code not a single test
uh you know there's a few reason that
you know that i i decided to pick you
know it's good living documentation good
for collaboration it's a good way to
encode invariants and basically express
to other engineers what you had in your
brain when you developed it
but there are two things
on the test driven development topic
that i want to touch on
so one is the concept of gold tests
which is essentially
tests that can only be modified by a
subset of the engineering team and the
reason you would want to do that is you
know you're going to have maybe five or
so or ten or so regression tests that
basically cover a very key aspect of
your system
and you'll make sure that only a few
amount of people can ever touch that so
you can change libraries you can evolve
how things
change internally you can change
messaging systems you can change you
know what database you actually back
your system by but those tests which are
like the golden tests that encode you
know the most important invariants
those you know should never need to
change
when you change kind of the underlying
mechanics
and by restricting it to a very small
amount of the team you basically create
an implicit
ownership group of people who are
directly responsible for making sure the
system actually behaves the way
that it should
and then obviously you can use you know
technology or not to do that
in very very big companies you wouldn't
want to have technology and post commit
or pre-commit hooks
but in smaller companies it's something
that's really easy
to introduce with just a comment
the other thing is having this notion of
expressive tests so basically tests that
transcend you know simple code but are
by themselves
kind of a domain specific language
and so i'll jump to one example that
comes directly from our code base
the system that it describes and we're
going to go through each step little by
little
is
is basically an accounting system that
receives events from many different
upstream processing systems and then
based on those events
decides what are the appropriate
accounting actions that need to be
applied
those accounting actions would be you
know we're going to increase your
account by twenty dollars and then by
the end of the day you'll get you know a
check uh electronically sent to you
and so what is basically going on is you
know you have a feed basically we're
pulling events from another system
and then you know we expect the system
to be in a specific state then some
things happen and then we expect the
system to be in another state and then
where you end up in the program you know
is obviously different than than before
and nothing that is described here is
actually tied to the implementation of
the system
so
at one point we had to change the back
end completely from one from one system
to to the other to be able to kind of
scale
to the next 10x and most of the tests
that were expressed
that way
didn't actually need to be rewritten we
were able to just take them you know
swap the implementation
and that actually gave us enormous
confidence that the new implementation
was exactly the same as before because
no one actually went there and rewrote
the test possibly with some bug in the
task being rewritten it was really just
a copy and paste
and reusing the files automatically
so then
another point on test driven development
and you know looking at it from another
angle usually what what i've noticed
in companies is everybody is super
gung-ho about doing tesla and
development right you speak about
someone who's working on his own little
project or
maybe two other colleagues
everything is going to be tested you
know there's there's no users but it's
really kind of a way of developing code
so you're in this you're in this space
where you know you're at the beginning
of your code base beginning of time
beginning of your of your company
beginning of your organization
the quality requirements on your system
are actually quite low because maybe
you're the only one who are using it or
maybe it's only friends and family who
are using your system so the asks on
your system are quite low
and then things evolve you know maybe
you raise a seed round or
you get a little more traction you get a
little more people who use it
and so you're going to kind of evolve uh
in the state where the asks on your
system the asks on the quality of the
system are increased and so maybe you're
able to kind of track
by automated testing but most of the
time you're going to start introducing
manual testing
and that could be as simple as you know
each time i do a deploy i actually go
through the website or i load up the app
and i make sure that it works right like
most people wouldn't look at that as
manual testing but really if you were to
classify it it's part of ensuring
quality
and it's part of the whole process of
doing code
and then
you know there's
two ways to go from there
one is
you know you continue to grow the
quality requirements continue to grow
and then things start to diverge very
quickly into two buckets
which i contend are non-overlapping
either you get sloppy and you don't
continue to do testing and you cover the
gap
by doing manual testing or
you continue to work on it and you're
able to keep that now maybe you do a
little more manual testing than you were
before but in proportion you're still
about in the same ballpark and then
obviously what happens from there is you
know you get completely diverging
kind of companies you know companies who
are
very slow at operating because they have
a very wonderful process to produce the
code and then very wonderful process to
test the code and then they discover
something as bad and they go back to
square one they redo the whole thing or
you get you know the companies that we
actually like to work at uh which etsy
is a very good example of um which
basically tests things you know and are
able to continue even with very very
high demands on their system uh to be
mostly
automated
uh and obviously you know caution retail
don't be that company
um so moving on uh into
what happens between blessing the code
and shipping the code
a lot is done about code analysis so you
have code and then you're going to use a
bunch of techniques
to be able to do to basically
vet that before the code goes to
production it's not you know going to
production yet but you're trying to make
one more determination on how that code
is going to behave
so what we've all learned kind of in
school is
the theory is very much decomposed
between static analysis which pulls
mostly from algebra
and dynamic analysis which pulls mostly
from code instrumentation algorithmics
and probability and because those two
fields of study are so different you
know most analyses are in one bucket or
the other
but then fast forward you know once
you're an engineer and you're actually
building system
the angle that we're looking at is you
know what tool can i draw from
and you know among all of the techniques
that are available to me
what should i draw from and
i think that a better dichotomy is what
you can draw from that will work
pre-production before the code is
actually running in front of customers
and things which run post-production you
know once you ship it to production and
very different than the static dynamic
kind of dichotomy
so
pre-production
type checking is what that you obviously
do for for languages which are type
checked uh java c plus plus go
um but even for dynamic languages you
know you can actually use
tools that will recover types you know
one of the projects that that i worked
on at google
was the google closure compiler which
basically tries to recover types in
javascript it was really instrumental to
you know being able to ship gmail you
know very very big code base
um and you know being able to kind of
organize the code of 30 40 50 different
engineers around it
and then obviously you know testing
which we covered you know linters
another example is what i like to call
the ford forbidden call analysis so in
regards of language regardless of
libraries you use there's always you
know this expert knowledge of yeah never
call this library because it doesn't do
what you want or never do things this
way or that way
and it's kind of a tribal knowledge
that's passed from one developer to the
other maybe it's going to be on a wiki
page somewhere
to actually encode it
into a test or into a linter or you know
some form of script that actually does
that automatically you know instead of
being tribal knowledge it becomes kind
of automated learning that you can
inject into your team you know it's
basically well run that tool and it'll
teach you about how to write code here
at our company
so that's all the category of basically
pre-analysis things that you would do
before the code chips
once the code has
the the major things are you're going to
log things you're going to gather
metrics you're going to monitor
um
you're going to do invariant checking
which is just a fancy way to do
to do monitoring you know if you're
denormalizing data maybe it's good to
actually check like once a day that
you're denormalizing correctly
because while your test may be correct
you know when you're in a nice sandbox
environment on your
ci machine when it's running in the wild
potentially with some concurrency issue
which is which are hard to debug you may
actually discover you know that there's
some uh incorrect denormalizations uh
yes we had like incorrect denomination
in some accounting systems you know
early on at square uh funny story it was
like three days before thanksgiving and
i noticed that
one of the operations basically inverse
the sign so basically we had you know if
you owed square money like you know you
uh we would try to debit your account
for 200
if we were unsuccessful at taking your
two hundred dollars it would come back
as a you know failed um you know failed
debit and then we would turn around be
like oh well now we owe you 200 here's
uh and luckily you know we had launched
only at beta and so i think we lost
under a thousand bucks because of that
bug uh but you know i projected that if
we had left that bug you know one more
week it would have been like 10x and
then one more week would be 10 more acts
which you know ends up being like real
money
um so speaking about metrics and
alerting uh i'd like to kind of do one
deep dive into
uh
metric versus checks so
what i call a check is you know what you
typically have in a monitoring tool like
nagios which is a very binary signal on
your system you know like you're you
have a probe you're looking at one very
specific thing of your system and you're
saying you know is it working or is it
not it's a very binary
kind of notion
so
the example i'd like to to go through
you know think about some ftp connection
that you have to some banking partner
and you need to be connected to that
partner to exchange files and so you
basically have a probe that is going to
check whether you're
connected to them or not obviously if
you're not connected you know some
engineer would get online maybe call the
bank try to debug what networking issue
is going on because you need to be able
to pass files back and forth
but as many of you know
banks actually operate in very
interesting ways which is most banks
close their system on saturday
so they're like well you know we're not
open for business we're just going to
shut down our systems
and so many of our partners actually at
square you know they're just not
available on saturday so we shouldn't
even try to connect so what we basically
code is uh there's you know 12-hour
period international checks where we
don't actually run the probe because we
know that it would be
flaky or give us you know
it would basically tell us that the
system is wrong
at other times obviously the system you
know
is indeed wrong which is uh highlighted
by the little red thing and that would
basically trigger a correct page to an
engineer uh which would then you know be
investigated
but if you look at that you know from a
from a system standpoint and you know
from an operator standpoint you actually
don't get a lot of information in the
system and most importantly you're
unable to basically get insight into
that blue box
so
another way to do it is you know turn it
into
uh into a metrics like a binary metric
uh you know zero or one uh and run it
all the time and then you know you're
going to run your probe so you get the
raw data as a metric
but then you're going to have some
smarter analysis on whether you should
send the page or not so that's kind of
you know normal evolution number one
in in the case above you know the probe
itself is coded to have this 12-hour
buffer where regardless of the
underlying result it says things are
good
you know one more evolution you know
really going into the world of metrics
is to actually measure the time it takes
to connect
and then you know you get a much more
interesting
view into what is going on in that
system
and you're actually able you know if you
look at you know the red
on the very first line
compared to the metrics on the bottom
you're able to see the outage coming
along and so you can actually respond
probably much before the outage is going
to come along uh and so
you know
the whole point is you know try to kind
of challenge yourself you know whenever
you have those kind of binary signals
about your system you know challenge
yourself to think about how to turn into
something that is more continuous that
basically paints a bigger story of what
is actually going on
because you know in in a post
post-mortem uh uh you can actually get a
lot more insight about what's going on
another kind of angle another way to
look at
this world of alerting and monitoring is
to think about when should you page an
engineer which is very costly operation
because you're waking up someone
who actually you know whose primary job
is to write code and add value
rather than being interrupted
versus
issue a report
that can you know basically describe
outstanding issues that can then be you
know resolved maybe in a 12 hour period
24 hour period maybe in a one week
period
and so
one way to look at it is this two by two
matrix where you are you're going to
have whether the signal of of the outage
that is happening or about to happen is
precise or imprecise you know are you
able to basically determine
whether things are bad or not
and the other is do you need to respond
to that immediately or can you respond
with a delay so the first bucket is
actually quite simple which is
if
you can tell precisely
that there's a problem and you know that
you need to respond immediately then
obviously a page is the appropriate
answer
and an alert is going to be you know
appropriate
for all cases uh you know where a
deferred response is okay a report is
much better and so in in the previous
company i was at welf we actually built
a very complicated reporting system
where many systems would be able to
essentially issue reports and then in
the morning as the operator you know the
person on call you would basically log
onto that dashboard and you would have
to kind of sign off on every report
and we even had like some formatters
that would basically show you you know
lines of the report that were
interesting or anomalous or different
than the report you got the day before
and it was really kind of you know there
was a lot of work that went into kind of
this reporting system
and even in cases where you can you know
precisely that the problem uh is
occurring if you can have a different
response you know i contend that you
should force yourself
to respond to it in a deferred way
rather than interrupt you know
essentially your manufacturing process
and then
the other
the last case is
uh when things are imprecise and you
actually need to respond to it
immediately you know that should be like
a fatal flaw of the system like that's
something that
needs to be actively worked on you know
to be able to either push it into the
deferred zone or push it into
the precise zone
but that should be a red flag and it
should be like an architectural flaw
like these things should just never
happen
uh
does that kind of ring a bell
great
cool so moving on to maintaining code
one of the things that we do at square
which i love and i discovered
is fix it weeks so
every quarter we set a a way one week to
fix things and there's absolutely no
top-down mandate it's just hey here's a
week back do whatever you want to make
the world better you know it could be
open sourcing things it could be
documentation it could be working on you
know the alerts
it could be building a dashboard to be
able to see metrics better
we had someone build a debugging tool
where you could basically
use kind of the chrome developer tools
to see interactions between an ios app
and server side
you know it could be whatever you want
but it's really about you know let's
make sure we kind of pay our technical
debt
and that's been kind of a nice nice way
to also set the tone and said the
culture of you know let's care about
let's care about our system
oh yeah do we demo at the end of the
week um in some cases we have demoed
yeah
you know definitely show and tell to
other engineers or uh it can be you know
a demo in many different ways uh in the
early days of the company
the the the all hands that we have every
week which we call the town square i
would actually be all you know fix it
and it worked pretty well
uh up until the point where first of all
there were too many engineers to
actually show all the work that was
going on and it got too technical for
people to actually engage and so it was
done in in kind of you know poster style
or other ways uh but yeah usually there
is that aspect of you know kind of the
bragging of hey i did this great thing
uh which kind of reinforces the culture
another kind of cultural hack is um you
know when you log into a terminal in our
in our systems if you're in staging the
terminal is green and has a green prompt
when you're in production it has a red
prompt with a big red logo and that
actually wasn't always the case it came
out of an outage where you know an
engineer logged onto the machine had a
couple terminals open staging in
production obviously because it's always
like that that just happened
and he wanted to test something on a
redis host
and he was like okay well i'm going to
test it and he's like oh well it doesn't
work i guess i won't do that in
production
oh that was production
and then that happened
um and you know believe it or not like
that was like you know 20 minutes outage
because he took like some main redis
that was used for locking of our payment
system
and then we were like well you know if
we had colors it wouldn't happen so
let's just put colors
um
so when things
bad happen
uh you know post-mortem is really
important like again kind of a cultural
hack to some extent
or at least something to kind of
reinforce that focus on safety um and
at a high level the three things to
focus is you know
one like
once you actually do that like all the
time whenever something bad happens
we had people get stuck in an elevator
in our new in our new facilities in san
francisco we did a postmortem you know
we actually analyzed you know why
and a big focus is to make sure it's
blameless
it's really about you know learning
rather than finding who actually had the
you know who was at fault for the issue
because if you look at an organization
the size of square but really any kind
of software organization or any kind of
manufacturing organization
it's a failure of the organization
to have issues in production and have
issues arise um you know in front of
customers it's not like you can't
hire you know really well and you know
hire great people and then look at them
and tell them well you know you just
need to be smarter like that doesn't
really work like it doesn't actually
logically compute and so you know if the
outcome of your postmortem is well you
just should not have done xyz you're
basically telling the person you should
just be smarter
and that shouldn't be an acceptable
answer out of postmortems
so
you know ways to do it is like
go through a timeline so that everybody
in the room is actually in sync of what
happened
it's also a really good forcing function
to gather precise forensics it also
highlights you know maybe flaws in
logging metrics et cetera where you're
unable to gather forensics after the
event so you're not even able to kind of
debug what happened
and then you know what happened well you
know there's always good things that
happen in an outage maybe the team
collaborated particularly well maybe you
know a system had been properly
decomposed or modularized such that even
though it failed the impact on the
customers was actually small
and there's always kind of good things
to actually come out and you know learn
from and push on
then things that actually didn't go bad
didn't go well and then things that went
really really really terrible
and so we actually put it in those kind
of three categories
you know smiley neutral
sad face
and then most postmortems should have
action items uh you know they should
have some follow through something
actually happened so you should take at
least one action um
in the early days you know at square we
used to come out of a postmortem with
like 20 30 different things that we had
to do it's like well you know we should
like uh you know improve the linux
kernel so that it does this
automatically and you're like well we'll
never just work on that like you know
come on we have a bunch of features to
build um and so we actually forced
ourselves to have no no more than two or
five action items like something very
manageable that everybody in the room
can actually nod to and say yeah you
know we can realistically get that done
in the next week or two
and it's also kind of a good forcing
function to be realistic about what you
can improve in the moment
and if those postmortems happen you know
if there's more and more outages
then there's other kind of techniques
that can be used
the other thing
is to kind of focus on on root cause
analysis and try to kind of understand
you know what was the actual issue
but the secret is you know there is no
root cause uh like
like it's pointless to even look at it
you know uh it just doesn't exist so we
had this funny outage at least in
retrospect it's funny
where
a network engineer had to change a
router on our systems uh and so very you
know simple operation
basically unbinding some ports and
re-biting others
except that there were two lines and he
copy-pasted and you know didn't change
like the second line correctly had it
reviewed by someone else that someone
else looked over the shoulder was like
yeah that's fine you know ship it
and so
he goes on the router you know does that
action
lights goes on
and he's like okay well i'll just you
know undo roll back you know end of the
story
except what he had done is he basically
cut the cord
between our main
payment system and a cache that it was
using
which shouldn't be a big issue except
instead of using the cache as a
secondary store
that payment system had to bug and use
it as a primary store and so
by cutting the cord the system you know
went into trash mode
launched a bunch of exception those
exceptions made it to actual clients
like client apps you know ios and
android those applications went into
a mode where you know if they're unable
to run the card they're going to
automatically void
the card
by
if you think about what happens when you
process a transaction the client
that you have in your hand needs to
issue
an identifier that is going to uniquely
identify the transaction it's client
issued you send it to the server
and then the server you know once it
processes gives you back an identifier
that it has assigned
but when you're unable to even process
the first one you actually need to issue
basically a reversal called a void with
your client id that you generated uh and
so all the clients that were trying to
process credit cards you know they were
over 10 000 concurrent requests over
that one minute where the network outage
happened basically sent voids
to our system except we forgot an index
on that query and because it happens
really really rarely we had never
noticed and so all of us all of a sudden
all of our database fell down
and it took an hour to recover and it
really took like
pulling all the cords shutting down all
the machines and then rebooting the
system
and you know that's the kind of thing
where the root cause is a copy paste and
a little networking issue
but really there were just so many
things that were broken uh you know it's
just kind of pointless to actually try
to pinpoint you know the root cause it's
always in a combination of many many
different things
one more thing um
that i'll leave you with is
kind of a template for postmortems um
again very simple thing to have
it could be a google doc it could be a
markdown document uh it's just a good
way to actually have a standard of
performance for what a postmortem is to
basically raise the bar
on what do we intend a postmortem to be
to basically raise the temperature when
everybody goes into a room they know
that either you know someone actually
spent time compiling that report or
someone will need to spend time
compiling that report and it's something
that we actually care about as a company
and so all those little things uh
actually kind of raise the temperature
on you know the importance of that of
that action
and then
one thing you know the one thing that
i'll leave you with and kind of end the
talk by
is this concept of proportional
investing uh you know we were speaking
about the number of action items that
you need to have out of postmortems the
thing is if you get more and more
outages uh you know something systemic
is going on and a nice metric to have in
your in the back of your mind is you
know this concept of proportional
investing which is
if you're spending 20 hours of your week
to fight outages you should spend 20
hours of your week to actually improve
your system
if it's 30 hours then spend 30 hours
improving it if it's two hours then two
hours and this way it's kind of a
self-stabilizing system where when
things go bad you spend more time making
them better when things are fine you
don't over invest in your technology you
don't over invest in all your tools
and over time if you're actually you
know true to kind of this principle
you're able to kind of keep you know
a nice kind of up and down and gentle
way to actually manage and improve your
system and over a long period of time
you know two three four years you know
you would be amazed by the amount of
progress that you're able to do through
simple things like that
i'll just go through these quickly
you can all read them
but what i would really say is
technology is great uh culture is even
more powerful and you know a culture of
safety and a culture of
of um
of
building code and building things in a
way that is you know focused on the long
term you know it doesn't happen by
accident and something that needs to be
really kind of built in every step of
the way like we did a big survey of many
many different little things
and all those things are actually
important kind of building the the
overall
the overall company
so with that you know i'll take i'll be
happy to take any questions and
take it from there thanks
so automated testing yen
uh
oh yeah
this one
yeah yeah yeah um sure so usually when
you're developing
um
you know you're super deep in your code
you're like super deep in building your
system
and you assume that things around you
are going to behave one way it could be
very simple things such as i assume that
no one is going to call my function
with a null value
you know if you're in c or c plus plus
or java and so what i mean by that is
you know it's very easy to write a test
that says well if you pass nolan to this
function i expect it to throw a no
pointer exception so you're basically
encoding the fact that you know this
method is not supposed to do null
checking it's supposed to throw up
and so it's even more powerful than
writing it in documentation because
documentation will get stale
and you know it you know take that
concept and you can kind of expand it to
many other things you know it's like
i'm getting this you know object or this
message from this other system i expect
those five fields to be filled in if
they're not then you know my function
will just misbehave et cetera et cetera
how does that
translate to
your
like
takeover like tests
because when you're writing tests on
that level yeah and you can't really
describe things that are like
that
uh i mean to some extent those uh those
tests which are you know the gold tests
or or tests which are expressive uh by
definition they're coding they're
encoding invariants because they're
encoding you know the behavior of your
system which should be an environment
meaning you know regardless of the
implementation of your system which is
meant to be fluid
uh you know it needs to behave exactly
that way
so it's yeah it's another kind of
super macro way to encode it in variant
no
any other
yep
called ownership
in the sense when you have a stable
space
that's been tested then i'm sure
everything works
but people that originally
left the company many many years ago
yeah and now it's kind of like
lower in the company
yeah
so
what do you think is the best approach
is it kind of
not best practice but is it sensible to
actually to forcefully go through all
the code and touch all the code to make
sure that everybody in the company is
actually aware
so basically if i understand the
question is you've got a large code base
that is mostly stable
the most people who wrote the code base
are not in the company anymore
like what'd you do
well first of all you try to retain your
people better
but realistically
you know there's going to be two
scenarios one is you actually have
automated testing which i assume given
the fact that you said it was stable
and so you should be able to rely on
that to be able to evolve it
but if you really have you know a team
that actually has no idea of what the
system is doing like you will need to
proceed with you know extreme caution
right you'll need to evolve that system
you know much slower than you would
evolve other systems because
there's a difference between being able
to do a change to a code base and you
know modifying you know with the
alignment of whatever the architectural
mindset was there right and so before
you can do big strides and big
modification to that code base you
actually need to get an understanding of
what were the architectural
you know what was the architectural
mindset
that actually produced that system
to be able to kind of predict you know
two years from now that's where we need
to go and so you can basically have a
spine
that basically is going to help you go
through that
on the other side if you don't have any
tests on a major code base that very
very little people know
step number one would be probably to
start you know testing or at least doing
some scenario testing at a macro level
to make sure that you know subtle
changes that seem innocuous don't have
major impact on on the outside
does that
answer the question
but what would be the best approach
other than trying to retain the people
they actually somehow
still have awareness of what
what is
uh testing is probably really good
uh like you know testing we're going to
have 90 unit testing 10
large tests or scenario tests and then
design docs
like design docs are actually
if they're well written can be very
useful
you know they have a tendency to get
stale but at least they give you an idea
of you know the thought process that
went to building it so that you're able
to kind of
understand the pitfalls that were
considered and were not taken
yeah
yep
when you talked about gold tests you
said that only certain engineers were
authorized to change them
what's the reason behind that extra
level of protection on the tests i mean
it sounds like
experience
yeah yeah so the experience so the
question is
you know when you have gold tests uh you
know i said there should be a limited
set of people who can touch it you know
why why the extra layer and the extra
protection
so
it comes from uh you know the my
previous company was a trading firm and
so we basically
uh you know operated a big kind of
brokerage uh and so
we deployed continuously to production
literally every five minutes
and you could come into the company you
know commit code on your first day and
it would launch like we actually had
someone in an interview build a full
feature that made it by the time they
left the company by the time they left
you know
the the
uh you know at the end of the interview
day
and so we were kind of afraid
that you know major bugs would be
introduced in the accounting system uh
and so
it was mostly a realization that
with all of our awesome testing
we are still kind of vulnerable to
making rudimentary mistakes that would
pass all of our unit tests
but not but actually cause you know some
some failure and so
by restricting to
basically the three people who were the
most knowledgeable in that training
system it added friction into the
process where if you're touching
anything remotely you know you actually
have to have a real interaction with
that person you know sit down with them
uh
and you know is is kind of forcing
function there so one is technological
which is you know you're going to have
first of all you're going to create
those gold tests and you're going to put
more thoughts into
you know if if push come to shove what
are the things that i really need to
protect and two you know it's kind of
this realization this humility that you
know with all of our super technology
things still bad could happen it's good
to force interactions
maybe last one or none
all right
cool thanks